andy and thomas bonara have three
biological children
but when they heard about five siblings
separated in different foster homes
they immediately adopted all of them
now they are a family of ten living
under one roof
here is their story
i love my big family because they're
always so kind
i'm andy and i'm thomas and we live in
magnolia texas
and we have eight amazing children hi
i'm sadie
i'm david i'm debbie i'm daphne
my name is thomas this is joey my name
is cora
hi i'm grayson hi robin how old are you
[Applause]
we have always wanted to have a big
family he comes from a big family
a big italian family he always thought
we'd have a home and wanted to fill it
with a lot of love so we had three
children
and i have always had a heart for foster
and adoption i always knew that's
something i wanted to do so
we we thought about it for a while then
in 2016 we started
looking into getting licensed for foster
and adoption
there's so many kids that need homes and
i just feel like
we can take that opportunity to share
love and
provide a consistent loving home for
other kids who need it
around fall of 2017
we went to the hospital to pick up our
now adopted two-year-old son bryson we
fell in love with him instantly
but about six months after he came to
live with us we found out that he had
four siblings
and that they were split up in different
homes and
immediately we decided we had we wanted
to adopt them
these kids come to our home with a lot
of trauma
and they need a lot of healing and
as i'm getting to know these precious
babies more and more every day they've
been with us now
thanksgiving will be two years that
we've all been a complete family
i i can't stop saying that i'm the lucky
one i can't believe i was picked to be
their mom because they are so amazing
since cove had started we haven't been
able to go out to the movies or get out
of the house as much as we wanted to
we've had movie nights at home and just
crowded on the couch
with all the blankets and the pillows
and the bearded dragon
and it's been a really great bonding
time one thing i like about movie nights
is that it always has popcorn to go with
it
i would say our biggest hopes is that
they grow up happy
they grow up uh you know being kind and
caring about other people and that
whatever their dreams are that there's
no obstacles that will stand in their
way
of them achieving them
family you are so incredible and this
year we've all had to stay home and miss
out on some of our favorite activities
and for the bonnaroo family
that's meant giving up going to the
movies so
walmart plus and i teamed up together
and we thought
if they can't go to the big screen let's
deliver the big screen to the bonnaroo's
i don't backyard you guys are gonna
freak out
so walmart plus is this brand new
membership that gives you free
unlimited delivery mobile scan and go
member prices on fuel and more and it's
a wonderful life hack
that saves you time to do more of what
you love so we gave this
incredible family a totally plussed
up movie experience and i recently
surprised the bonnaro family over
zoom to get the fun to begin take a look
[Music]
okay so my boss is coming in in just a
second to say hi
okay
i can't believe this i'm i am such a fan
i grew up watching you
i i don't know how you juggle all of it
by the way
hi guys i'm drew
do you have any tips for parents out
there that are juggling a lot
for me the thing that gets me through is
just not
being serious all the time you know it's
just
they're amazing kids and i can't believe
i was picked to be their mom
i love you guys and i know
that you guys uh like to watch movies
too yeah oh yeah i mean yeah
so we're gonna do a droovy night and
um i've worked at walmart for 10 years
now
and they're starting this new program
walmart class
and with them i am going to build a
backyard movie theater
in your house if that's okay she's gonna
build a backyard movie theater
i'm just so surprised this was so
unexpected
hey y'all my name is kelly and drew has
sent me here to create the most ultimate
movie night for the bonnara family
we have spent so much time picking out
every single last
detail and we are so excited about this
and we can't wait for you to see it
ready to do this
yes
[Music]
we are going to start building so we've
created three different areas we have
the lounge area
we have the dining area that's right
behind me and of course we have the
amazing
outdoor movie theater
so when drew and i were designing the
backyard we really wanted this movie
area to be the focal point and so no
matter where you are in the backyard
you'll be able to see the screen
[Music]
so it's the end of the day our crew's
been here all day long and they've been
working so hard and it is hot we are in
texas people it is hot we are
melting we are excited we are drew's
crew and we can't wait for you to see
this
i'm so excited for you to see this
incredible backyard
movie night that we helped create for
the amazing bonnera family
check it out
[Music]
so every single item in this space can
be found at walmart
from the large items like the sofa to
the small items like the pillows
and everything to the candy jars and the
popcorn tins
everything's looking amazing and the
family's gonna love it
[Music]
oh
oh my gosh this is amazing
are y'all ready to see your ultimate
backyard
movie experience yeah
[Applause]
okay ready set go
[Applause]
get out of town
oh my
[Music]
is this our backyard oh my gosh like
they have all their
names what do you think this is amazing
wow wow
thank y'all so much oh my gosh that was
horrible
[Music]
one of the areas we wanted to create for
you was a dining room area outside
because
i mean who doesn't want to eat dinner
breakfast lunch whatever it is outside
thank you so much that's amazing and so
we wanted to
give you a little bit of an extension
off of your current porch and so we
added this
deck oh it's gorgeous so we could give
you a lounge area
oh right and this ramp yeah chloe yes
joey thank you you can get up look they
remembered that
yes of course absolutely then you can go
up the ramp and
the whole family can just hang out oh
this is amazing i can't even think of
any other words like i'm
just like speechless this is so gorgeous
we want you to be speechless this really
touches my heart
i really appreciate it
hi bonnaroo family surprise and welcome
to your new backyard
where we have set up the ultimate movie
night for you to enjoy
we spent so much time choosing each and
every item specially
just for you guys i want this to be a
place where you can have fun
relax and create beautiful memories
and i want you to kick it off tonight by
watching any movie you like
i'm sending so much love and we'll see
you guys soon
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh wasn't that amazing and the
bonnaroo family is here and now to tell
us all about it hi guys
[Applause]
oh my gosh it was amazing i i couldn't
even believe
how beautiful everything looked the
colors
just the popcorn and all the candy it
was just
i mean it made me speechless it was
amazing it was such an
awesome memory and it just gives us
a chance to make more yes it has just
been so much fun
to work with you guys truly
oh my gosh drew i'm such a fan and
i can't even believe this thank you so
much for picking us
because just being able to talk to you
and
um have this experience and be
planning future memories is just the
most
amazing thing and just thank you so much
it's funny that you say that because i
was so excited to have you guys on the
show because i think
that you are the living example of
kindness
and generosity in the world
and i'm so happy to have been a part of
your family
and your journey through building this
movie night with walmart plus
this is going to be a memory of our time
with you and and just the whole process
and i'm just i'm i'm so excited that we
were able to
um experience this with you and
just get to meet you and i
i just my family were just so thankful
and
can't wait to start making more memories
i
when we got off our zoom call that
lasted a good
i don't know 45 minutes i immediately
felt like like we were good old friends
andy
i really connected with you and
i think that you're such an amazing mom
and an amazing woman
and your whole family is really i just
think that
all of your spirit and by the way
i mean i i that everybody is like
standing together
and like behaving by the way and being
so great
i'm so impressed and so proud we all
have families here
and um i'll be checking in with you guys
if you don't mind because it's been so
nice getting to know you i would just
love to check in and say hi
and keep in touch oh we would love that
we'd love for her to
check in with us sometime right guys
thank you for being a part of our show
and i also want to give a huge thank you
to walmart plus for being a part of this
and for bringing back so many missed
moments for you guys
join on walmart.com plus
and see how walmart plus delivers
you